chers amis quel immense joie d'être avec
vous ce soir ici au cannet et de vous
retrouver tous et je voudrais commencer
en vous disant de tout coeur en disant à
chacun d'entre vous un immense merci
pour votre présence ce soir
jean-eric l'on dit le fait de vous voir
si nombreux et déjà en tant que tel un
très grand signe d'espoir et c'est le
fait que vous soyez là qui porte la
dynamique qui nous conduit aujourd'hui
dans cette campagne c'est votre présence
partout en france partout où nous allons
avec laurent avec tous nos colistiers
avec agnès et arnaud c'est votre
présence partout votre confiance et
votre soutien qui nous porte et qui nous
pousse à tout donner pour vous avec vous
pendant tous les jours qui viennent et
qui nous séparent du 26 mai merci
infiniment
michel de nous accueillir chez vous
c'est une joie d'être ici dans le sud
dans ce département dans cette ville où
notre famille politique a vécu de si
grands moments où elle vivra encore j'en
suis sûr comme c'est le cas encore ce
soir tant de bons moments encore grâce
au travail que vous faites
merci eric de ton accueil dans cette
fédération que tu portes dans ce
département où nous savons à quel point
être de droite mais pas une honte
être de droite ne suppose pas qu'on
s'excuse de ce qu'on pense
et tu portes aux cette voie que nous
venons de t'entendre dire encore devant
nous ce soir
je voudrais te dire cher eric à quel
point j'ai été touché de ta confiance
dans cette élection pour laquelle je
m'avance devant vous ce soir de fête
c'est une chance pour moi que nous
soyons si nombreux mais c'est aussi une
chance qui m'engage et se veut dire qui
m'impressionne est presque qui
m'intimide comme l'a dit jean tout à
l'heure
comme l'a dit jean tout à l'heure c'est
vrai je n'avais rien demandé mais pour
une raison très simple c'est que je ne
pensais pas mérité quoi que ce soit
et de fait je n'ai pas mérité la
confiance qui m'a été faite cette
confiance est un pari c'est un pari fou
c'est un pari incroyable j'espère être à
la hauteur de ce pari mais ce pari nous
le devons seulement à laurent wauquiez
je voudrais dire à quel point je sais
parfaitement que d'autres auraient sans
doute lui bien plus de compétences bien
plus d'expérience bien plus de
légitimité que moi pour porter ce grand
défi j'ai été frappée que dans une vie
politique si souvent rongé par
l'individualisme par les égoïsmes
solitaire j'ai été l'objet de la
confiance de ceux qui auraient pu
prétendre à exercer aujourd'hui cette
responsabilité et je voudrais dire en
particulier à quel point j'ai été touché
de ta bienveillance cher jean chaire
jean leonetti toi qui est depuis le
début m'a montré à quel point cet
engagement qui est le tien était celui
qui partageait qui fait partager des
valeurs plutôt qu'elle ne sépare de fait
peut-être certains ont pu douter
certains ont pu se demander si c'était
le meilleur choix
je voudrais leur dire très simplement
que je ne leur en veux pas parce que je
me suis posé les mêmes questions est ce
qui compte c'est que nous soyons
ensemble se soient rassemblés
il n'y a pas contrairement à ce que
disent certains il n'y a pas d'effet
bellamy il y a seulement un effet
famille enfin réunis il y a seulement un
effet famille enfin réunis autour d'une
clarté retrouver autour de conviction
partagée autour d'un projet fort et
clair et c'est cela qui nous porte et
j'ai eu la chance d'être investi depuis
le début de cette campagne avec agnès
evren avec arnaud danjean avec lesquels
nous avons partagé les premiers moments
difficiles parfois de cette campagne
européenne et qui m'ont beaucoup appris
et qui m'ont beaucoup enseigné arnaud
parlementaires européens sortants
spécialiste reconnu en europe des
questions si importante de lutte contre
le terrorisme
de défense de sécurité et qui m'a
beaucoup pensé nié depuis le début ce
qui pouvait permettre d'ajuster au mieux
notre projet et notre parole pour
pouvoir être le plus efficace demain
dans l'action que nous porterons j'ai
été rejoint depuis nous avons été
rejoint par tant de colistiers qui
apporte de toute la france leur
compétence leur expérience leur regard
sur notre europe
c'est cela qui fait la force d'une
équipe politique je n'ai jamais été ma
chronique parce que je n'ai jamais cru
que le nouveau monde et est forcément
meilleur que l'ancien
et pour ma part je crois au contraire
que ce qu'il y a de meilleur dans le
nouveau c'est toujours ce qui a été reçu
de l'ancien et que ce qui fait la force
de nos communautés humaines toutes nos
communautés humaines est d'abord de nos
familles comme de la moindre des équipes
municipales dans la plus petite des
communes comme de la plus grande des
aventures qui peut être est celle qui
nous lie aujourd'hui dans ce moment si
singulier de l'élection européenne ce
qui fait la force de toute communauté
humaine dans une entreprise comme dans
une association c'est la complémentarité
magnifique entre ce qu'il faut de
renouvellement d'imagination et de
créativité
mais ce qu'il faut aussi de compétences
de savoir faire qui se transmettent pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions être
efficace comprendre le monde qui vient
et relever ensemble les défis qui se
présentent à nous oui c'est ensemble que
nous sommes portés par ce bel élan
c'est ensemble que nous avançons et je
voudrais remercier tous ceux qui sont
ici tous les élus je ne vais pas tous
les citer tous nos élus qui portent avec
nous cette campagne comme ils portent
tous les jours la vie de notre
démocratie dans les tensions qui
traversent notre société
ils sont ceux par qui tient aujourd'hui
le pays qui est le nôtre et qui tient
par le terrain grâce à eux bien plus
qu'il ne tient par le haut je voudrais
remercier tous les élus les maires les
conseillers municipaux les conseillers
départementaux
les conseillers régionaux bien sûr nos
parlementaires qui incarne cette liberté
dont certains peut-être ray préféré
qu'elle se taise
mais qui est bel et bien vivante grâce à
eux ils sont notre voix ils sont ceux
qui représentent la force de notre pays
et nous pouvons les applaudir ensemble
ce soir
et puis je voudrais remercier bien sûr
tous mes colistiers tout ce qui
m'entoure dans cette campagne
ils sont nombreux ici ce soir je
voudrais citer simplement ceux qui sont
de ce département que vous avez entendu
s'exprimer et qui représente si bien
cette belle complémentarité
un ancien professeur un ancien étudiant
bernard et xavier merci d'être là pour
porter avec nous cette campagne se
défient le fait il faut que nous
puissions être à la hauteur de ce défi
qui se présente car ce soir nous sommes
heureux de nous retrouver bien sûr mais
nous avons tous dans le coeur une forme
de gravité qui a déjà été exprimé par
ceux qui m'ont précédé à cette tribune à
ce pupitre
si nous sommes ici ce soir c'est parce
que nous sommes tous animés d'une
question le pays dont nous héritons la
civilisation que nous avons en partage
va-t-elle encore durer dans le monde qui
se dessine pour nous encore transmettre
cette culture que nous avons reçues et
l'avoir durée pourrons nous voir nos
entreprises notre économie continuer de
prospérer pour nous reconstruire cette
société traversée de temps de fractures
et de tant de tension et je crois que
sur tous les grands défis qui attendent
notre avenir la réponse passe par
l'europe mais je crois que si toutes ces
questions se posent aujourd'hui c'est
aussi parce que l'europe n'a pas été à
la hauteur des défis de notre temps et
c'est parce que trop souvent l'europe
nous donne le sentiment de nous
fragiliser dans la mondialisation au
lieu de nous renforcer sur tous ces
grands défis sur le défi économique et
commerciale face à cette guerre qui se
joue souvent au dessus de nos têtes en
chine aux états unis
face à cette concurrence dont nous avons
l'impression de devenir de plus en plus
souvent les spectateurs résigné own au
lieu d'en être les acteurs conquérant
face à la question migratoire questions
fondamentales bien sûr parce que
l'avenir de notre monde en dépend face
aux défis écologiques et
environnementales qui nous préoccupe
tous autour de cette mer méditerranée
qui connaît directement toutes les
pollutions qui viennent s'y déverser
fasse aussi évidemment à cette
inquiétude culturel que nous éprouvons à
cette crise de la transmission qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons le sentiment
que nos enfants nos petits enfants
n'apprennent plus à l'école les éléments
les plus fondamentaux d'une culture et
d'un savoir qui pourront leur permettre
de trouver leur place dans notre société
face à tous ces grands défis la réponse
passe par l'europe nous en sommes
convaincus et nous sommes les héritiers
de ceux qui ont fait l'europe parce
qu'il savait que nous serons plus forts
ensemble que si nous restons isolé mais
face à tous ces grands défis nous savons
aussi très bien qu'aujourd'hui l'europe
que nous avons construite n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
et depuis le début de cette campagne
j'entends partout en france monter
l'inquiétude et l'angoissé de ceux qui
ont le sentiment que l'europe parfois
nous manque que parfois elle nous fait
défaut que parfois même elles nous
trahis
c'est le cri d'inquiétude de cet
agriculteur qui me dit j'ai toujours cru
à l'europe mais moi qui ne parvient pas
à m'en sortir alors que je me donne tant
de mal quand j'ai vu que l'europe
acceptait de faire rentrer sur notre
marché commun des centaines de milliers
de tonnes de soja ogm comme interdit de
cultiver
alors j'ai dit pour moi l'europe c'est
terminé eh bien à cet agriculteur là
comme à tant de chefs d'entreprise qui
vivent la même expérience comme à tant
de mer qui ont le sentiment que l'europe
sert plutôt à produire d'énormes
artificielle qu'apporter des projets
fort à tous ceux qui ont le sentiment
que l'europe n'est pas derrière eux pour
pouvoir les renforcer mais que parfois
trop souvent elle organise cette
concurrence déloyale que nous subissons
qu'elle organise notre impuissance à ce
cri d'inquiétude de cet agriculteur je
ne crois que je ne peux pas lui répondre
en lui disant qu'il est un populiste
qu'il est un méchant mais je crois que
notre seule responsabilité c'est de
construire une europe de refonder une
europe dans laquelle plus jamais un
agriculteur ne puisse poser une telle
question de refonder une europe
dans laquelle plus jamais une telle
angoisse ne puisse s'exprimer
et oui c'est vrai parlons de ce défi
fondamental qu'est le défi économique et
le défit commercial
il faut enfin sortir de la naïveté
nous étions cet après midi grâce à jean
à sophia antipolis pour rencontrer des
chefs d'entreprise qui aujourd'hui
travaillent dans le monde et qui incarne
l'excellence de nos savoir faire
mais ces chefs d'entreprise nous
disaient qu'ils ont le sentiment que
nous sommes dans une forme de paralysie
que nous nous imposons à nous mêmes nous
avons construit ce marché unique qui est
une force extraordinaire qui pourraient
l'être en tous les cas mais qui est
aujourd'hui trop souvent réduit à n'être
qu'une proie qu une cible facile pour
ceux qui viennent y commercer alors qu
ils nous interdisent d'échanger avec
leur propre état le saviez vous chers
amis en europe 20% du pib est constitué
par les marchés publics et biens de
marchés publics sont ouverts à 95%
nous sommes les seuls au monde à donner
le signe de cette ouverture
car les marchés publics américains ne
sont couverts qu'à 30% les marchés
publics russes à 0% les marchés publics
chinois à 0%
comment est il possible qu'une
entreprise chinoise puisse venir faire
du profit en france alors qu'une
entreprise française jamais ne pourra
conquérir un marché public en chine
il est temps de sortir de la naïveté et
c'est ce que nous pouvons faire ensemble
c'est ce que nous pouvons faire qu
ensemble j'étais il ya quelques jours de
cela à londres et je rencontrais nos
amis britanniques qui regardent
aujourd'hui avec un peu de regret cette
aventure du bric citant se disait en se
disant qu'au fond il y a d'abord un
espoir qui semblent s'évanouir pour eux
qui est celui d'obtenir d'autres
partenaires commerciaux d accord qui
soit favorable
même les états unis finalement peuvent
contourner le marché britannique
aucun acteur international ne pourra
contourner le marché européen avec 60
millions d'habitants
n'importe quel grand acteur de ce monde
qui se dessine peut contourner nos
règles et nos lois mais avec ce marché
commun de 500 millions d'habitants nous
avons une force extraordinaire si nous
voulons bien faire de ce marché enfin
une force politique
si nous voulons bien sortir de la
naïveté si nous voulons bien comme tu le
disais ne pas en rester seulement à une
doctrine de la concurrence qui a pour
but de faire en sorte que le
consommateur puisse vivre avec le
produit le moins cher mais de retrouver
un cap industriel une stratégie
économique pour pouvoir fixer de
nouveaux une aventure pour l'avenir une
capacité d'investir nous redonner une
stratégie qui nous permettent de
transmettre à ceux qui nous suivront une
économie prospère ne pas en rester
seulement à une europe qui fait
appliquer des normes mais dessiner cette
europe qui peut devenir un acteur du
monde qui se dessine un acteur au
service de l' équilibre de ce monde et
notamment bien sûr de cet équilibre
écologique dont nous avons tellement
besoin car cette naïveté à laquelle nous
avons si longtemps cédé elle a produit
la catastrophe économique que nous
connaissons
elle a produit la catastrophe sociale
que nous avons vécu mais elle est aussi
directement responsable de ce problème
de ce grave problème de ce grave défi
climatique et écologique que nous avons
devant nous oui bien sûr nous sommes
préoccupés de ce défi climatique
il m'a parfois été reproché d'être
conservateur
je ne sais pas si ce mot peut suffire à
enfermer les grandes questions qui
attendent notre avenir mais une chose
est sûre je crois que nous le partageons
tous nous avons d'abord le désir de
transmettre à tous ceux qui nous
suivront notre culte
notre civilisation mais nous avons aussi
le désir de leur transmettre un monde
qui soit encore vivable et un homme qui
souhaite encore humain dans ce monde
encore vivable et pour cela bien sûr il
faut être à la hauteur de ce défi
écologique mais comment en être à la
hauteur si on ne s'attaque pas à la
cause et où est la cause du problème
climatique sinon dans cette
mondialisation débridée déséquilibré
dans cette mondialisation sans cap et
sans but qui a créé ce monde de flux
perpétuel dont nous héritons aujourd'hui
parce que nous n'avons pas su défendre
notre industrie et notre économie nous
vivons aujourd'hui ce qui est
directement la cause de ce déséquilibre
que nous déplorons le saviez vous
j'étais il ya quelques jours sur le port
de pêche de lorient avec alain cadec le
président de la commission de la pêche
qui est un membre de notre liste un
spécialiste européen de ces questions si
importante pour la france
cette question de la pêche et avec alain
nous parlions avec des pêcheurs qui nous
redisent est ce que je dis depuis le
début de cette campagne c'est un exemple
si parlant il n'y a en europe quasiment
plus aucune capacité de filetage du
poisson c'est à dire de traitement du
poisson quand vous mangez le poisson
sous forme de plats préparés
en fait il a subi un processus de
traitement que l'on appelle le filetage
mais comme nous n'avons quasiment plus
aucune capacité de filetage en europe le
chemin qu'il a fait est généralement le
suivant un poisson qui est pêché au
large des côtes de l'ecosse et emmenait
souvent en chine pour pouvoir être
traitées et ensuite il est ramené en
france pour pouvoir être consommés avant
d'arriver dans votre assiette il a fait
des milliers de kilomètres et ensuite on
explique aux salariés français qui a
besoin de sa voiture pour faire 10 km
pour aller travailler que c'est lui qui
responsables de la crise écologique et
que c'est lui qu'on va taxer
jusqu'à ce qu'il comprenne qu'il est un
absolue et bien moi je vous le
dis ça n'est pas raisonnable et si nous
voulons nous préoccuper de la crise
écologique il faut s'attaquer à la cause
est la cause c'est précisément cette
mondialisation débridée dans laquelle on
a cru trop longtemps que toute
l'industrie serait en chine et qu'en
europe on allait faire des services et
des loisirs
mais ça ne pouvait pas fonctionner ça ne
peut pas fonctionner il nous faut
réapprendre à produire ce que nous
consommons et c'est cet enjeu la majeur
qui est devant nous et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons de créer
une barrière écologique une barrière
écologique qui fera que désormais sur le
marché européen
ceux qui voudront importé devront
respecter les mêmes règles que ceux qui
produisent en europe parce que nous
n'avons pas parce que nous n'avons pas à
nous imposer cette concurrence déloyale
que nous organisons nous mêmes il faut
sortir de la naïveté il faut faire en
sorte qu enfin nous puissions contrôler
la manière dont ceux qui viennent en
europe importe et agissent en europe et
c'est tout le sens du travail
extraordinaire qu'a mené franck proust
au cours des dernières années
franck est parmi nous ce soir et qui est
le responsable de notre famille
politique au parlement européen franc
qui a fait voter qui a contribué à cette
avancée importante pour faire voter
enfin au parlement européen un mécanisme
de contrôle des investissements directs
étrangers sur le sol européen pour que
nous ne puissions pas voir petit à petit
nos actifs stratégiques captée par
d'autres acteurs
une europe qui sortent de la naïveté
c'est je crois celle qu'il nous faut
refonder pour apporter notre
contribution à ce nouvel équilibre dans
le monde a besoin dans ce monde de
grandes puissances qui se dessine autour
de nous dans ce monde d'excès du bri
dans ce monde de démesure l'europe doit
apporter sa contribution à l'histoire de
notre époque
elle a si souvent contribué à l'histoire
du monde parfois pour le pied et souvent
pour le meilleur et bien il est temps
d'apporter encore le service que nous
avons à rendre à ce monde de demain en
constituant ce nouvel équilibre pour la
mondialisation que l'europe doit être
enfin ce poumon d'un nouvel équilibre
qui nous permettra de nouveau de
regarder l'avenir avec confiance et de
regarder avec fierté
l'excellence de nos savoir faire la
force de nos entreprises
qui pourront de nouveau retrouver cette
compétitivité que des réformes
indispensables aussi bien sûr en france
lui auront redonné ensemble redonner un
équilibre à notre monde c'est aussi bien
sûr faire face à ce grand défi que le
défi migratoire
car ce défi migratoire n'est pas passée
et je m'étonne bien souvent que dans les
débats que j'ai pu vivre depuis le début
de cette campagne on met parfois
opposées que la crise migratoire était
fini tiens donc nous dit on vous parlait
l'immigration met enfin en voyons la
crise migratoire c'était en 2015 c'est
terminé tout cela est bien mon cher ami
nous le savons très bien ce qui nous
voulons sortir de la naïveté si nous
voulons bien ouvrir les yeux sur le
monde de demain
nous devons le dire avec force la crise
migratoire n'a pas encore commencé elle
est largement devant nous parce que la
démographie du continent africain qui
est de l'autre rive de cette
méditerranée que nous avons en partage
la démographie du continent africain va
constituer l'occasion d'une pression
migratoire plus forte que jamais si nous
ne savons pas sortir de l'impuissance
dans laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui et
si nous ne savons pas sortir de cette
impuissance
alors nous allons continuer de produire
du malheur à grande échelle malheur pour
nos sociétés qui sont déjà profondément
déstabilisé par une immigration que nous
n'avons pas su maîtriser et qui est
arrivé si nombreuses que nous ne savons
pas l'intégrer aujourd'hui je le dis
comme enseignant tant de jeunes
grandissent en france piégée dans la
spirale d'un communautarisme qui les
prive de se reconnaître dans une
communauté républicaine et nous n'avons
pas le droit de ne rien faire de ses
avertissements qui nous sont lancés par
tant de voix aujourd'hui jusqu'à celle
d'un ancien ministre de l'intérieur
socialiste qui quittant son ministère
nous a alertés aujourd'hui nous vivons
côte à côte
demain peut-être nous serons face à face
nous n'avons pas le droit de ne rien
faire d'une telle
malheur pour nos sociétés mais malheur
tout autant pour tous ces jeunes venus
d'afrique auquel des passeurs sans
scrupules tendent le miroir aux
alouettes d'un eldorado qu'ils ne
trouveront pas en arrivant en europe et
à tous ceux qui nous font de grands
discours de générosité à tous ceux qui
comme le président de la république le
faisait jusqu'à il y a peu de temps à
tous ceux qui vantent la nécessité de
l'ouverture et la volonté de
déconstruire les murs eh bien je
voudrais dire avec vous venez porte de
la chapelle
venez danser lieu de nos villes où
vivent aujourd'hui tant de ces jeunes
venus de tous les coins de l'afrique qui
viennent se retrouver dans cette impasse
que constitue l'europe pour eux ils
avaient cru trouver un lieu où ils
auraient leur place où il pourrait même
s'engager pour soutenir leurs familles
en fait ils se trouvent piégés parce que
nous n'avons pas de quoi les accueillir
et que la première règle de toute
humanité consisterait à leur dire cette
vérité qu'il faut maîtriser nos
frontières et que leur place est en
afrique pour développer leur pays et non
pas chez nous en france
maîtriser nos frontières c'est tout
l'enjeu de cette action européenne dont
laurent vous reparlera maîtrise de nos
frontières c'est tout l'enjeu de cette
politique de la double frontières que
nous voulons construire ensemble pour
qu'effectivement une action européenne
forte puisse être mené car nous croyons
que cette action européenne est
nécessaire et nous ne sommes pas de ceux
qui comme le rassemblement national ont
voté contre tout ce qui pouvait
renforcer l'europe face aux défis
migratoires mais nous croyons aussi à la
différence de monsieur macron que chacun
de nos états doit pouvoir garder la
maîtrise de sa politique migratoire et
c'est le sens de cette double frontières
que nous défendons ensemble et puis
enfin bien sûr tout le défi qui est
devant nous c'est celui de cette
civilisation qui cherchent à se
transmettre qui cherchent en elle même
des raisons de se transmettre
si nous devons faire en sorte que ce
défi économique et commerciale soit
relevé si nous devons faire en sorte de
maîtriser nos frontières c'est d'abord
parce que nous croyons que nous sommes
les héritiers d'une histoire qui mérite
d'être continuer et je voudrais
m'arrêter avec vous un bref instant sur
ce sujet qui me paraît essentiel ce qui
fait la force des grandes puissances que
nous regardons dans le monde avec
parfois un peu d'inquiétude
ce n'est pas seulement la vitalité de
leur économie ce n'est pas seulement
l'efficacité de leur industrie
ce n'est pas seulement la force de leurs
de leurs armées respectives
mais c'est d'abord la conscience très
fortes qu'elles ont ces grandes
puissances de porter une culture une
civilisation et d'agir au nom de quelque
chose qui les précèdent et qui les
dépasse et c'est sans doute d'abord cela
que nous avons perdu jean tu l'as dit
paul valéry nous le disaient les
civilisations sont mortelles mais aucune
civilisation ne meurent parce qu'elle a
été attaquée et nous serions bien
inconscient de nous faire croire à nos
même que ce sont nos adversaires qui
nous menacent aujourd'hui toutes
civilisations meurent d'abord de cet
oublié elle même
et c'est peut-être
et c'est peut-être bien sûr ce qui est
arrivé à l'europe si nous avons été
déshérités en effet c'est d'abord parce
que nous nous sommes refusés à nous même
de transmettre cette civilisation que
nous avions en partage c'est peut-être
parce que nous avons été incapables de
nommer cette civilisation qui nous porte
de dire quelle est notre culture nous
avons élu un candidat à la présidence de
la république qui nous avait expliqué
qu'il n'y a pas de culture française et
je crois que mes ne disons pas trop de
mal de lui il n'était pas en cela un
problème mais un symptôme le symptôme
d'un oubli dont il n'était pas le seul
acteur dont il n'est pas le seul auteur
d'un oubli qui dure depuis trop
longtemps depuis plusieurs décennies
comment se fait-il que nous ayons pu en
venir à croire qu'il n'ya pas de culture
française alors que des étrangers du
monde entier viennent en touristes
découvrir notre culture nous sommes le
premier pays touristique au monde celui
que le monde entier vient admirer celui
que le monde entier vient découvrir
parce que le monde entier sait qu'il y a
une culture française et qu'elle mérite
d'être goûter et qu'elle mérite d'être
admiré et dire cela ne doit pas dire
cela ne doit pas nous faire sentir
orgueilleux de ce que nous n'avons pas
produit nous mêmes nous sommes d'abord
des héritiers dire cela c'est seulement
nous sentir obligé nous sentir les
obligés de ceux qui nous ont précédés et
qui nous ont légué cette histoire
magnifique
monsieur macron n'était pas le premier à
commettre cet oubli comment se fait-il
que la france est était d'ailleurs aux
avant postes lorsqu'ils y a quelques
années dans ce débat un peu absurde
nous avons refusé d'inscrire dans les
traités fondateurs de l'union européenne
la mention de nos racines car l'europe
ce n'est pas d'abord un projet
l'europe ce n'est pas d'abord des
traités l'europe ça n'est pas d'abord
une commission des comités l'europe
c'est d'abord une histoire c'est d'abord
un élan c'est d'abord un héritage c'est
vous l'avez rappelé ce petit miracle
fragile de la naissance de la raison qui
commencent à poindre au cinquième siècle
grecque dans les cités au bord de la
méditerranée qui allait peu à peu porté
à tout le monde méditerranéen le sens de
ce qu'est la liberté lorsque par les
forts de cette raison entrer en dialogue
nous construisons cette expérience
magnifique qui s'appelle une démocratie
pour parler ensemble de l'avenir que
nous voulons plutôt que de le subir
l'europe c'est le sens de l'égalité de
tous devant la respublica devant la
chose commune le sens de cette égalité
qui mûrit dans l' empire romain et qui
se transmet par lui à tout le monde
latin et l'europe c'est aussi évidemment
et pourquoi ne pas le dire
pourquoi avons nous tant tardé à le
nommer l'europe c'est le moment de cette
prise de conscience de la dignité
humaine qui s'opère progressivement à
travers la tradition chrétienne la
tradition judéo chrétienne qui marquent
notre continent
dire cela ce n'est pas seulement se
tourner avec nostalgie vers un passé
révolu
ce matin une ministre du gouvernement
disait sur une chaîne de télévision
qu'en parlant de ses racines
nous nous comportions comme des
nostalgiques romantique et passéiste et
bien nous voulons dire à madame de
montchalin que si pour elle nommé nos
racines que si pour elle reconnaître
notre histoire que si pour elle se
tourner vers cet héritage que si pour
elle vouloir transmettre cette culture
si pour elle tout cela c'est être
passéiste nous lui laissons le privilège
de cette triste considération car nous
savons les premiers qu'il n'y aura pas
d'avenir pour notre pays si nous ne
savons pas nommé de nouveau nos racines
si nous ne savons pas dire qui nous
sommes il n'y a pas d'avenir pour notre
société
si nous sommes incapables de dire la
force de ce qui nous lie la force de ce
qui nous relie la force de ce qui fait
ce bien commun que nous avons en partage
et dans lequel chacun d'entre nous peut
se reconnaître français et européens à
la fois oui bien sûr
oui bien sûr face à tous les grands
défis qui menacent nos sociétés il faut
des réponses techniques il faut des
réponses pratiques
oui bien sûr l'europe dont nous héritons
a permis de construire la paix et cette
paix est aujourd'hui menacé bien sûr
nous n'allons pas entrer en guerre
demain contre l'allemagne
mais la guerre ce n'est pas seulement
cela la guerre c'est aussi ce qui frappe
durement notre pays déjà à travers le
terrorisme islamiste qui traversent nos
sociétés et qui a touché si durement à
nice qui a touché si durement dans notre
pays au cours des dernières années la
guerre et la violence c'est ce à quoi
l'europe doit aujourd'hui réagir si elle
veut rester elle même est bien face à ce
terrorisme islamiste il faut des
réponses policières bien sûr et nous
avons au coeur de notre projet cet
engagement de pouvoir renforcer une
coopération européenne sur cette
dimension policière il faut des réponses
judiciaires bien sûr et nous avons au
coeur de notre projet ce qu'il faut de
propositions pour conforter une réponse
judiciaire européenne face aux défis
terroristes mais à la fin nous ne
gagnerons la guerre contre le terrorisme
islamiste
nous ne gagnerons la guerre contre la
gangrène de l'islam radical que si nous
savons re dire qui nous sommes
car cet islam radical avec toute sa
violence et sa brutalité est venu
remplir le vide que nous avions
nous-mêmes l'essai et c'est la raison
pour laquelle
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
n'est pas être passéiste que de se
tourner vers cette histoire qui nous a
fait ce n'est pas être passéiste que de
reconnaître la valeur des biens que nous
avons dans nos mains au contraire c'est
reconnaître que ces biens sont notre vie
notre vie d'aujourd'hui et notre vie de
demain je crois que c'est ce que nous
avons tous ressenti tous lorsque nous
avons vu il y a quelques jours dans ce
moment éprouvant et pourtant
singulièrement émouvant lorsque nous
avons vu il y a quelques jours brûlé le
toit de la cathédrale de notre-dame de
paris
nous avons tous sentis en même temps que
nous étions atteint touché dans nos
coeurs dans nos esprits dans nos tripes
presque retourner parce que nous étions
en train de voir et nous avons senti
alors que c'était quelque chose de nous
mêmes qui étaient en train de brûler
j'ai eu l'occasion cher xavier
d'échangés il y a quelques jours avec le
général qui commande la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris pour aller lui
dire notre infinie reconnaissance et à
travers lui à tous les hommes qu'il
commandait ce soir là pour l'acte
incroyable qu'ils avaient fait en
préservant pour nous et pour tous ceux
qui nous suivront cette cathédrale
inestimable
je crois oui cher xavier que à travers
l'engagement qui est le tien à travers
l'engagement qui est celui de tous ceux
qui comme toi s'engage pour notre
sécurité se joue quelque chose de
fondamental pour la vie d'une société
qui est le sens de cette solidarité qui
nous lie je le dis avec un peu de
gravité parce que c'est cela que
l'europe peut être aujourd'hui menace la
règle d'une directive et d'une norme
totalement absurde est en train de
menacer directement le principe même du
volontariat des sapeurs-pompiers de ces
sapeurs pompiers qui veille toute la
nuit sur notre sécurité qui veille à la
fin de leur journée de travail pour que
bénévolement par leur engagement ils
puissent apporter cette proximité des
secours que notre modèle de sécurité
civile apporte aujourd'hui à chaque
français eh bien c'est ce modèle qui est
aujourd'hui menacée et nous nous
battrons je te le dis avec toi cher
xavier pour défendre ce modèle de
sécurité pour défendre ce modèle qui est
d'abord un modèle de solidarité et de
civilisation est le général qui
commandait la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris avec lui nous
méditions sur cette expérience qui
pardonnez moi de revenir à mon tropisme
professionnels et presque l'occasion
d'une méditation philosophique
lorsque la cathédrale brûlés le choix a
été fait d'envoyer des hommes monter
dans les tours de cette cathédrale pour
tenter d'arrêter lé incendie qui
menaçait d'atteindre les poutres qui
supportaient les cloches
si l'incendié les avaient touchés ces
cloches se seraient effondrés et les
tours se serait écroulé avec elle
le choix a été fait d'envoyer des hommes
dans ces tours comme d'autres pompiers
dans les tours du 11 septembre aux états
unis
mais cette fois il n'y avait pas de vie
humaine en jeu et pourtant ces hommes
sont montés et ils ont risqué leur vie
ils ont risqué leur vie alors qu'il n'y
avait pas de vie humaine en jeu ils ont
fait infiniment plus que leur devoir
aucun d'entre eux me disait le général
n'a manqué à l'appel ils sont tous
montés en sachant qu'à tout instant ces
tours pouvait
crowley ils sont montés pour aller
sauver non pas des vies mais des pierres
parce que ces pierres sont vivantes
parce que ces pierres sont notre vie et
que nous soyons croyants ou non que nous
soyons croyants ou non le pouvons nous
reconnaît nous pouvons nous reconnaître
dans ce lien magnifique qui fait je le
crois profondément la condition de notre
avenir le choix qu'ont fait ces hommes
n'était pas un choix passéiste ça
n'était pas un choix nostalgique
ça n'était pas le choix d'un romantisme
suranné c'était le choix de la
responsabilité absolue
il faut restaurer notre dame de paris
mais il faut bien sûr aussi restaurer ce
lien qui nous attachent les uns aux
autres ce lien qui nous unit et qui est
la condition pour que nous puissions
nous reconnaître dans un avenir commun
c'est d'ici qu'est partie cette culture
extraordinaire des rives de la
méditerranée et de ses îles de lérins
cher david d'où partent aujourd'hui
encore tendent aventure magnifique c'est
d'ici qu'est partie cette culture et
cette civilisation et c'est d'ici sans
aucun doute qu'il faut nous attacher à
la refonder car nous ne serons plus une
société ne seront plus une nation si
nous ne savons pas dire qui nous sommes
et si nous ne savons pas quel est ce
lien qui nous unit
nous n'avons aucune chance de vaincre
l'islam radical si nous ne savons pas de
nouveau donné à tous les jeunes qui
grandissent en france quelque chose a
aimé et qui s'appelle la france et qui
s'appelle l'europe et qui s'appelle cet
héritage
nous n'avons aucune chance nous n'avons
aucune chance de sortir de ce piège qui
est la france archipel décrit par jérôme
fourquet si nous ne savons pas que nous
ne sommes pas qu'une addition de
communauté qui s'ignorent les unes les
autres mais que nous sommes une
communauté réunie par cet héritage
commun qui nous vient d'une histoire
ancienne mais qui est notre présent
notre être d'aujourd'hui et qui est ce
par quoi nous pouvons nous projeter dans
l'avenir et ce par quoi nous pouvons
faire confiance à notre possibilité de
rayonner encore longtemps dans l'avenir
et dans le monde
alors oui c'est vrai c'est ici sans
doute c'est ce soir qu'il faut dire
notre souhait est de refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la france et comme
c'est d'ici qu'est partie cette
civilisation magnifique pour irriguer
tout le monde de la grèce antique et
tout le monde de l'empiré romain
tout ce monde de la chrétienté de
l'héritage judéo-chrétien tout ce monde
des lumières tout ce monde de la
modernité critique qui fait de nous ce
que nous sommes
parce que c'est d'ici qu'est partie
cette aventure magnifique
c'est ici aussi que doit partir sa
refondation nécessaire car film nous ne
savons pas faire ce choix alors nous
sortirons de l'histoire mais si nous
savons faire ce choix
nous avons toutes les raisons d'y croire
encore nous avons toutes les raisons de
croire encore dans cet avenir qui est
devant nous de faire confiance à la
force de nos entreprises à l'excellence
de nos savoir-faire à l'énergie de tous
ceux qui partout en france travaillent
encore malgré toutes les difficultés
malgré le découragement malgré la peine
malgré les règles qui viennent d'en haut
et qui semble inhibé asphyxié l'action
ce qui aujourd'hui porte et font vivre
la france et font vivre l'europe ont
largement de quoi donner à cette france
et à cette europe un avenir radieux
rayonnant un avenir plein d'espoir et
c'est ce qui est en jeu dans la promesse
qui nous associe ce soir nous voulons
refonder l'europe pour pouvoir rétablir
la france alors pour pouvoir relever ce
défi magnifique nous avons besoin de
vous je vous le disais tout à l'heure je
ne suis que le porte-voix humblement et
modestement de cette équipe magnifique
avec laquelle nous portons ce défi
derrière toi laurent derrière toute
notre famille politique je voudrais être
votre voix mais j'ai besoin pour cela
que vous soyez aussi nos voix il nous
reste 24 jours 24 jours 24 jours pour
convaincre 24 jours pour ramener à nous
tous ceux qui doutent
tous ceux qui ont été déçus tous ceux
qui ont été déçus par la politique et
disons le aussi tous ceux qui ont été
déçus parfois par notre famille
politique
vingt-quatre jours pour leur dire qu'il
est temps d'y croire encore que nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix que d'y croire
encore que de faire ce pari fou de
l'espoir parce que nous avons toutes les
ressources pour espérer pour espérer
encore longtemps pour agir et pour
rayonner mais qu'il est temps maintenant
de faire les choix nécessaires pour être
à la hauteur du défi qui se présente à
nous aujourd'hui le 26 mai il faut que
nous puissions faire ce choix
définir ce cap clair pour pouvoir
dessiner l'avenir de cette europe que
nous voulons au service de notre france
le 26 mai cette victoire qui se dessine
c'est vous qui leur est conquise ce sera
votre victoire nous la devons à notre
pays de la devons à notre europe
vive la france et vive l'europe merci
infiniment
[Applaudissements]